how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about everything
relating to Marvel and of course
everything relating to the MCU and today
we have some x-men news some quite
interesting x-men news in a report that
says Marvel for one story of the x-men
is going to take it in a different way
that you probably never expected to see
on screen an adaptation of an old comic
book run and the animated x-men series
from the 90s now we know that Marvel
Studios wants to do something different
with the x-men than Fox did the x-men
films towards the end weren't really
that well received and very well liked
by the fandom so Marvel Studios is going
to want to stay way clear from that do
totally different storylines and add
different x-men characters and that's
exactly what they're going to do and
I'll break down this new report that we
have today in this video but if you're
new be sure to subscribe so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU and to enter this week's giveaway
which is a Captain America Avengers
in-game Funko pop all you got to do is
subscribe like the video and comment
down below so this report is coming from
Mikey Sutton and in his report he says
Professor X isn't the only scientific
genius Marvel Studios will be adding
once the formerly Fox properties begin
to appear in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so a few months ago back in
November of 2019 Mikey initially
reported that the Savage Land will be
featured in an upcoming x-men movie and
in this report he says that he has
received additional albeit tentative
plot details about what could possibly
function as the second x-men film
meaning that when there finally is an
x-men film in the MCU it won't be the
first one but it will be the second one
his name is dr. Karl Lykos an old
college chum of Professor X and he
mysteriously disappeared while on an
expedition joined by his mutant students
Professor X's search takes him to the
Savage Land where he is shocked to
discover that Lycos has changed
transformed into a pterodactyl like bean
who now calls himself Sauron in Mikey's
report he says that this is an early
basic premise of what will evolve into a
polish storyline that will draw
influence from both its comic book roots
and x-men the animated series from the
90s the line
for the x-men is still awaiting a final
decision but apparently havoc will be
among them here in his original scoop
Mikey included appearances from kazar
and Shauna and he says that both
characters are still being discussed to
appear in this film as like OSes friends
before he became surin he concludes by
saying that Suren is not considered to
be the main phone in this little world
of dinosaurs especially a devil dinosaur
the Jack Kirby creation who is being
tweaked into the Savage Land he says
that the main villain is going to be the
guy who changed like ghosts into surrond
and who that person is he is dropping
that news exclusively on the Lords of
the long boxes YouTube channel and I'll
link them down below now as I said in
the beginning this is certainly not
something that many fans would have
expected to be adapted on to the big
screen or silver screen if they decide
to go to Disney Plus but the Savage Land
actually has a ton of connections to the
x-men the Avengers and spider-man and
the Savage Land is just one part of
earth it's in Antarctica so having it in
the story of the x-men just like from
the comic book run could really set a
lot of things up for the future not have
an entire movie revolved around one
specific area but having characters come
out of it having characters go into it
briefly for some stories would be really
cool to see on the screen it would be
very different and very cinematic and I
think would be really cool to see
on-screen but let me know what you all
think about this would you like to see
the Savage Land story be adapted onto
the big screen let me know what you
think in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
with notifications turned on so you
don't miss out on anything relating to
the MCU be sure to follow me on Twitter
for live updates and as always thank you
all so much for watching we'll fluff